euro einstehen hessen nicht total
erledigt gin tonic be wo ich nehme dich
mal mit mir leben das den auslauf der
auf blauen ersten hallo leute ich jetzt
wieder einmal waren willkommen zu einer
neuen folge wie schmeckt heute machen
wir die süßigkeiten lasagne schrägstrich
auflauf von angelo ich auflaufe es gehen
so 2016 lässt grüßen die spacken der
angelo nicht kennt das ist eine cartoon
serie die es auf tour geht also super
rtl dort habe ich jetzt den klub
gefunden und ihr habt ihr ganz oft in
die kommentare geschrieben
vanessa bitte mach den süßigkeiten
auflaufen manche von euch haben auch
geschrieben dann gesondert beraten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die story hinter dem süßigkeiten
aufläuft ist die dass angelo und lola
sehen dass die mama ganz erschöpft ist
und sie wollen das kochen für sie
übernehmen in denen sie den rosenkohl
auflauf machen menschlich gesehen für
mich abstoßen und statt der original
zutaten benutzen sie süßigkeiten na klar
es sind kinder die wollen nur
süßigkeiten essen
kinder kamen mir zu den zutaten diese
gleichung keine sorge war schmettow
gummi fische und jetzt machen wir den
ball flach
nach und nach machen wir diesen auflauf
und da setzen jede zutat jede gesunde
zutaten durch eine ungesunde oder süße
zutat und zuerst haben sie den spargel
und den ersetzen sie durch grüne ab wie
schade sie sagen grüner apfel lakritze
aber ich glaube weil es aus
amerikanischen von der hand jetzt müssen
wir die scheelen der assistent
ich kann so ist ein mal und wie das maya
wer mich so vieles mehr
es sind auch diese abfall von der
krebsstation kleinen müssen was zu
machen ist meine schuld an den hat wir
schmeißen jetzt weg bei dem rauchen wenn
ich mehr geld
weißt du das haben wir heute weggemacht
ist so dass man jetzt auch machen die so
tief 1 das ganz schön tief ehrlich
gesagt dass es nicht einfach wird bin
laden und dann eigentlich so tief wie
erhofft schon wie meine
kammer vom ok oder jetzt brauchen wir
für das originalrezept eine jetzt müsst
jetzt
[Musik]
jetzt müssten wir eigentlich eine tasse
tee zu hätten aber wir kriegen die
kinder sind quatsch motto ist das unser
auflage vor
ja das kommt dann kommen vielleicht ist
er dazu oder das hast du über links von
den koreanern wo der schiffbau oder
schriften nur damit dass nicht alles so
ankläger soll es um irgendein kräften
jetzt hätten wir die auflaufform ein
damit nichts anklebt also wie so ein
spiel dem packen jetzt mal die
abgeschaltete reihe also die aktuelle
krise irgendwie sieht aus als ob es ein
rezept werden könnte oder ist schon geil
aus jetzt haben wir noch so theike
eigentlich darüber muss ich sagen so ein
apfel schale mit
so und jetzt brauchen wir steigen jetzt
du ein paar maß reduziert so einfach
wir müssen uns ja echt ans original
letzter zeit nicht mehr so wichtig sagte
dass ein geheimtipp wird laufen noch
nicht zu 100 prozent daran aber es wird
ja die band die pilze die waschen also
wir haben grüne carolis anspruch
[Musik]
findet sich alles in die hand
meine kein wird so greenpeace nehmen wir
an statt rosen ruhig dies sei auf
glauben popkomm als ersatz gekauft nicht
ob also die letzte zutat sind seitige
jährige dass die einzigen beiden unis
waren die auslagen also optisch analog
woanders ist dieses traums ist dieses
die fisherman's geschichten so dass der
sowieso ein fischer auf ein cooles
styling ist am sonntag bedient
frühstücken nein allergisch glaube ich
so hart verdienen bekommen auch rein
dann schließen wir den gin richtig
aussagen würde wohl passieren wenn er
jetzt noch mal kurz rein gucken würde
wir stehen jetzt im ofen sie gut aus
oder doch
so profis hätten natürlich jetzt den
großen vorgewärmt immer der schlimmste
gefühl ziemlich sicheres gefühl da ist
kein platz vorgefahren korrekt zu hoch
macht mehr habe ich das hier noch mal
hier kein jetzt esse ich verstehe dich
schon gar nicht mehr wer panetta ich
wollte jetzt schon immer meinen um video
dabei sind und frage die ich jetzt
jedoch vorstellen möchte
glaubst du nicht schmecken mein neues
format
nein es gibt schon grund warum ich mich
davor gedrückt hat diese die lasagne zu
machen und mich darf mit 30
es könnte also ende von der geschichte
die essen den und die finden den alle
ganz super ich vielleicht eine
überraschung drin sagt nicht ab wenn die
karamellisierte ab lakritz apfel haut
sich um die kaugummis wickelt und den
disput hier machen wir dann gemacht
oder kommt sie nicht der auslauf kommt
jetzt in den u 12 uhr mitternacht also
let's go eine bande gehören
er wiegt gehören wir holen jetzt den
auflauf aus dem ordnungsrecht nicht so
scheiße sie rissen nach java da
abgegangen alter bub erlitt muss man
dann vielleicht und pop verlieht einer
von uns heute sagen sie kauft wenn das
so explodiert wie denkst das ist unser
auflage schmecken die apfelscheiben die
teilweise recht richtig verbrannt
oh mein gott das ist schon richtig
cremiger auflauf geworden immer nicht so
richtig öffnen kann so auch schon
support auch mega ich hab hunger bis hin
zu wenn ihr noch nie gesehen und wir
haben auf race kanal bürger gemacht
einen zettel burger peter gab es also
wenn ihr hier fertig seid geht drüber
merkt euch das sagen soll ich am ende
noch mal gerecht und hamburg ausgenommen
aber schon länger her
das geht mir auf den youtube kanal von 2
kümmert das schon mal schief gegangen
das direkt für mich ja dass mein
lieblingsstück auch bekommen
diese wesselmann die kleine ecke mit
ganze krise ja sozusagen immer wenn man
aufgabe gemacht das steht was man dann
auf dem teller hat sieht ja nicht so gut
aus ja stimmt wie es schmeckt dann ich
kenne doch zu kurzen dafür nichts
schlimmer als kelly scott und jetzt
stellen wir uns wieder der aller wichtig
frage wie ich der süßigkeiten aus lauf
aus
[Musik]
aber einen ganz großen bis jetzt mal an
die familie machte
[Musik]
schmeckt's nicht obwohl der apfel gibt
es ist eher so an weihnachten oder so
was brauchen wir müssen mal dessen wahl
dafür war für die familie ist schon
richtig aber ich werde das mit dem
abschmelzen
das ist auf jeden fall absolut das kann
im moment ist also dieser apfel da gibt
halt wirklich viel ab dass wird schmeckt
jetzt alles so als wären solche ab wippt
irgendwie weißt du ist das jetzt gerade
weiter so schränkt kannst nicht sagen
ist halt ein weihnachtssingen so schön
zugangs oder so so als mann fehlt trotz
das noch weniger käse fahren ein trend
geht nicht ja genau in langenargen genau
gedanken auf punkt damit ist dann wartet
auch kommen
wenn man das video von dem bad gegessen
kann es wirklich liebe sein
ich fand's super lecker wie fandest du
es wenn wir noch mehr rezepte sehen
wollten die ich bei ihm schmeckt's nach
mache dann steigt sie mir auf jeden fall
in die kommentare
dankeschön an alle leute die das hier
auf jeden fall empfohlen haben geil
jetzt wisst ihr wie es schmeckt bei
canon immer boxen klar
12 es ist cool ich bin doch mal nein das
passt noch mal noch mal okay das ist
jetzt auch die betrinken sitzt